This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6Nate English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English.
I'm Rob. And I'm Sam.
Having your photograph appear on the cover of a magazine
makes you famous around the world.
But imagine if that photo showed you hugging and playing with wild chimpanzees.
That's exactly what happened to Jane Goodall, who shot to fame in 1965
when she appeared on the cover of National Geographic magazine.
Jane introduced the world to the social and emotional lives of the wild chimpanzees of
Gumbay in eastern Tanzania.
Jane spent years living among families of wild chimpanzees.
Her observations changed the way we view our closest animal relatives,
and made us think about what it means to be human.
In this programme we'll be hearing from the iconic environmentalist Jane Goodall.
She reflects on how attitudes have changed as science has uncovered the deep connections between
humans and the great apes. Large primates including chimpanzees, gorillas and orangutans
who are closely related to humans.
And of course we'll be learning some related vocabulary along the way.
As well as Dr Goodall, the National Geographic photographs
also made the chimpanzees of Gumbay famous.
People around the world became interested in the lives of a family of chimps
living in a remote corner of Africa.
When Gumbay's alpha female died in 1972, she was so well loved that she had an obituary
in the Times newspaper. But what was her name? That's our quiz question.
Which chimpanzees obituary appeared in the Times?
Was it a Frodo, B-flow or C-Froid?
Well 1972 is a bit before my time, Rob. I wasn't even born then, but I think it's B-flow.
Okay Sam, we'll find that later if you were right.
Now, when Jane first visited Tanzania in the 1960s, most scientists believe the only animals
capable of making and using tools were humans.
But what Jane witnessed about the behaviour of one chimpanzee, who she named greybeard,
turned this idea on its head. Here she recalls that famous day to Jim Al-Kalili
for the podcast of BBC Radio 4's Discovery programme The Life Scientific.
I could see this black hand picking grass stems and pushing them down into the termite mound
and pulling them out with termites clinging on with their jaws.
And the following day I saw him pick a leafy twig and strip the leaves. So not only was he using
objects as tools, but modifying those objects to make tools.
Jane observed the chimpanzee greybeard, finding small wooden branches called twigs
and modifying them, changing them slightly in order to improve them.
By stripping away the leaves from twigs and using them to collect ants and termites to eat,
greybeard had made a tool, an instrument or simple piece of equipment for example a knife or
hammer that you hold in your hands and use for a particular job.
Previously, it was believed that animals were incapable of making tools on their own.
What Jane saw was proof of the intelligence of wild animals.
Jane Goodall's studies convinced her that chimps experienced the same range of emotions as humans.
As she explains here, to BBC Radio 4's The Life Scientific.
I wasn't surprised that chimps had these emotions. It was fascinating to realise how many
of their gestures are like us so you can watch the without knowing anything about them.
And when they greet with a kiss and embrace, they pat one another in reassurance,
they hold hands, they seek physical contact to alleviate nervousness or stress.
You know, it's so like us. Holding hands in racing and kissing with some of the chimpanzees'
gestures, movements made with hands, arms or head to express ideas and feelings.
In the same way as humans, the chimpanzees would pat each other, touch someone gently and
repeatedly with their hand held flat. Much of their behaviour was human-like.
Just as I would hug a friend to reassure them, the chimps used physical contact to alleviate stress,
make pain or problems less intense or severe. In fact, chimps are so alike us that sometimes they
even get their name in the newspaper. Yes, Sam, you mean the quiz question I asked you earlier.
Which chimpanzee had their obituary published in the Times?
And I guess it was B flow. And that's absolutely right, well done, Sam. Give yourself a pat on the back.
Aha, okay. In this programme, we've been hearing about legendaries,
aologist and activist, Jane Goodall and her experiences living among great apes,
primates like chimpanzees who are humans closest animal relatives.
Jane witnessed the chimpanzees of Gombe modify or slightly alter objects like leaves and twigs
to make tools. Hand-held instruments used for a particular job. Many of the chimpanzees' gestures,
body movements made to communicate and express emotions like kissing and patting,
touching someone gently and repeatedly with a flat hand were almost human.
And just like us, the chimps sought physical contact to alleviate or reduce the severity of
nervousness and stress. And that's all for this programme. Bye for now. Bye bye.